part of that fragile economy is the
stubbornly high inflation rate america's
treasury secretary janet yellen weighed
in on that in an exclusive interview
with our very own nancy cordes nancy
jones joins us right now with more on
that conversation nancy good morning
good morning nate this interview came on
the heels of that disappointing
inflation report and so i asked the
treasury secretary how long she thinks
this high inflation is going to last and
whether we are nearing the peak
not surprisingly she was unwilling to
make any predictions a lot of
predictions that have been made over the
course of these post pandemic price
hikes have turned out to be wrong but
here's what she did say
it is
top priority to bring it down the
federal reserve bears
a key responsibility for addressing the
inflation situation i'm not going to
comment on how they should do that but
i think it's clear they're very
committed to making progress and we hope
to see substantial improvement over the
coming year
i also asked her if she thinks in
retrospect that all the stimulus
spending over the course of the pandemic
contributed to the inflation that we're
seeing now she said at the time stimulus
spending was crucial for saving jobs and
keeping people afloat it's now expected
that the fed will raise interest rates
by as much as one point when the fed
meets next week in a bid to cool the
economy and lower prices gail
all right nancy thank you very much